president trump showing his support for
our military as he's set to visit walter
reed medical center today
president will meet with wounded combat
vets and health care workers who have
been
on the front lines in the fight against
covid19
former white house physician and gop
congressional candidate for texas rear
admiral
dr ronnie jackson joins me now to
discuss doctor thank you so much for
being on the program
uh good morning president going to visit
with combat vets healthcare workers
talk to me as you as you look at the
response as you look at
what he's done for our military your
reaction
well i just think it's a great thing i
mean i've been with the president i've
accompanied him
on these visits to the walter reed
national military medical center
on a variety of occasions and i think
it's a great thing that he does to get
out there
and visit those guys that have been over
there that have been deployed overseas
that are
injured that are coming back home and
recuperating he goes up there and he
talks to the
staff in the icus and in the awards and
tells them thank you for their service
it's just a wonderful thing that he does
and he's very uh he's very sincere and
very good about making sure that he does
that on a regular basis so i'm happy to
see that he's doing it
you know the media is going to run
breathlessly with is the president
wearing a mask or not wearing a mask you
know better than anybody else
this guy's the most tested person people
that
go next to him have to be tested what do
you make of their obsession about
whether he wears it or not
well i just think they're driving a
narrative here you know they're they try
to make the president look bad obviously
no matter what he does but you know
you're right the president and the team
and the team that surrounds him are
aggressively tested
and uh he'll go in there today and he
will uh he'll wear a mask when it's
appropriate he'll follow the direction
of the hospital commander
uh you know we all wear masks when we go
to hospital i visit real hospitals here
and i don't generally wear a mask and
most of the things i do during the day
but when i go to the hospital i put a
mask on
i'm sure the president will do some of
the same but the president is walking
the line he's
he's out there leading from the front i
mean he has to be an example of how
we're going to get this country back on
our feet again
and get us to work in the school again
as well so i appreciate the leadership
from the president and i think he walks
the line and he does it very well
doctor you're down in texas running for
congress
there has been an increase in testing
there just as around the country
uh there's also an increase in cases and
we've seen more deaths in texas due to
covet 19.
your response to the situation down
there in texas
well i think we we do have a lot more
positive cases and that is because we
are aggressively testing down here and
you would expect that when you're
testing you're going to get more
positive cases there's even a study out
by the cdc uh not too long ago that
showed that probably
there are 10 people out there that are
positive for every one person that
tested so there are a lot of people out
there that have this
now people are you know the one thing
that i have noticed up until recently
the reporting is that the
hospitalizations and the deaths are
trending down despite the fact that the
test numbers are trending up there's
some reports now that some of the deaths
are trending up a little bit but and
that's in large part i think due to
testing as well
people in the hospital are being tested
aggressively right now in the icus and
on the awards everyone's being tested
and if you have even if it's an
incidental finding that you test
positive for coronavirus
that goes down as a part of your
diagnosis for your hospitalization
and if you were to die in the hospital
for something that's going to be part of
your diagnosis uh
you know when you die and so i think
that those numbers aren't very accurate
i don't think i think that there's some
manipulation of those numbers
and i think some of it's being done
still for political reason
there you go rear admiral ronnie jackson
uh thank you so much for your time this
morning appreciate it
thank you thank you peter i appreciate
it